[DIGITAL EFFECTS]
PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So we'll start a
new chapter now,
QCD or quantum chromodynamics.
And then, this first
lecture of this chapter, we
talk about the
production of hadrons.
This is really meant as
an introductory lecture,
but we will also
already see some very
interesting and useful concepts.
So we want to produce
quarks and anti-quark pairs,
and we do this
electron-positron collisions.
We have studied in detail this
first part of the diagram.
Specifically, we
calculated a cross-section
of muon and
anti-muon production,
and we also have
seen more changes
than we have same
kind of particle
in the final state of the
electron-positron scattering
to electron-positrons.
So now, we've replaced
the muons with our quarks
and anti-quark pairs.
And the first step, we
want to remind ourselves
of the available quarks
in this discussion.
So we have the up quark, the
down quark, charm, strange,
top, and bottom.
You see that the
charges are given here,
and the photon
couples to the charge.
So the charge is not 1, but
it's either 2/3 or minus 1/3.
Third
We have also here
in the table mass
is given for those particles.
They range from a few MeV to
173 GeV for the top quark.
The bottom quark is
about 5 GeV heavy.
Remember, when we
discussed re-normalization,
we discussed that those masses
are not fixed parameters,
but in our perturbation
series, they
run like the [INAUDIBLE] one.
So that might cause some
difficulties later on.
OK so now we want to
produce an up quark
and an anti-up quark
in this collision.
So what happens?
So we now have
collisions, and then we
produce those particles.
So let's say an up quark,
and an anti-up here, and then
your plus and minus collision.
Those quarks only live
for a very short time,
or travel a very short
distance in space--
about 10 to the minus 15 meters.
And then, they
start to pull in out
of the vacuum gluons, and
quarks, and anti-quark pairs,
and those then form into the
actual hadrons after some time.
And those two pictures here
will look very much the same.
The difference is
the way we treat
the hadronization-- the actual
fact of forming hadrons.
In this first picture,
we are thinking
about clustering energy
particles together
and that way form hadrons.
In this picture here, we connect
them with so-called strings.
And those are two different
ways to model and model
the production of hadrons.
Remember, when we look
at this process here,
we are looking at
very low-energy kind
of or lower-energy
kind of phenomena,
and at lower energies,
the strength of the strong
interaction, the
strength of QCD, is--
the coupling is
on the order of 1.
It can be larger than 1.
So perturbation theory
is not possible.
That's why we need
specific models.
This is all I want
to say at this point.
We'll come back to this
discussion later on.
What I actually want to discuss
is what we can learn out
of measuring cross-section
of hadron production--
for example, by comparing
directly the cross-section
of [INAUDIBLE] production
with a cross-section we just
calculated for
muon/anti-muon production.
And experimental
results are given here.
So you see as a
function of energy,
here from 1 GeV to 7 GeV
center of mass energy,
and then the lower
plot just continuing
from about 10 to 60 GeV.
What you see here is that
there is a rich structure.
So you see those
resonances here,
and you also see that there
seem to be some sort of increase
in the value of this ratio.
So how can we now
understand this?
At leading order, we
can just write this down
we just calculate
its cross-section
for electron-muon scattering,
or for electron-muon production.
And we can write this
very same cross-section
of the leading order for
quark-antiquark production.
What we find as differences
is the coupling,
the coupling itself.
Here, we have to use
the charge of the quarks
and not the charge
of the electron.
So there is an additional
factor here, 1/3 or 2/3 squared.
And then, there's the number
of possible quark pairs
which are available,
and that depends
on the number of colors.
Remember, each quark appears
with three different colors,
so we have to account
for this factor.
All right, and then
we built the ratio.
And the ratio, everything
just cancels out--
great.
So we have just a
number of colors
times the sum of
the charges squared
of the quarks available.
What do I mean by "the
quarks available?"
As we go from lower-energies
to higher energies in this plot
here, the kinematic--
the energy is sufficient
to produce particles
based on the masses available.
So we find that this
explains a step function.
Let's look at a
specific example.
So if you look at center
of mass energies, which
are larger than 2 times the
mass of the bottom quark,
and maybe lower than 2 times
the mass of the top quark,
we are in this
specific regime here.
Can you see, this
is almost flat,
and the number we
get is almost 4, OK?
What we get from this
leading order calculation
is 3 times 4 over 9 for our
up quark, 1 over 9 for down,
1 over 9 for strange, 4 over
9 for charm, and 1 over 9
for our bottom quark, OK?
So we built the sum here
for all quarks which
are kinematically available, and
as an answer, we get 11 over 3.
So this is in very
good agreement--
a leading order,
very good agreement
with the experimental results.
11 over 3 is almost 4.
Excellent, so this
is clear indication,
experimental indication,
that this color factor here
is a real thing.
There seemed to be 3 up quarks,
3 down quarks, 3 charm quarks,
and so on.
And we also see that
this leading order effect
here, the leading
order calculation,
is already very precise.
And the reason for this
is that this process here
is a QED process.
So the production
cross-section is QED process,
as we just discussed.
So now, why do I actually
have this as part
of our QCD introduction?
First, you learned about
the color factor here, OK?
And second, there is,
indeed, corrections,
and one of the
correction is the one
where you actually produce a
real gluon in the final state.
And those corrections
can be calculated.
If you go to higher order,
you get a correction
from this radiated gluon.
You also get corrections
which looks like this--
vertex corrections--
and you find
that the correction here to
[? r ?] is about 1 plus alpha
s at a specific scale over pi.
Now, at a reasonable scale,
this is then about 0.1 the value
of alpha s, and
pi is 3.14, and so
you get about a few percent, 3%
correction to the r value rate.
Why is it so important when
there's a small correction?
It's a percent or few
percent level correction.
What is really important
is that this process can
be used in order to demonstrate
the existence of gluons,
and so gluons have been
discovered this way.
And the way this was done is
by producing the plus and minus
collisions and detecting
three bunches of particles--
too from the quarks,
and one from the gluons.
And then, to identify
that this gluon on here
is actually a gluon and
not some other particle,
one can look at
angular distributions.
One can identify that this is
a spin 1 particle, and so on.
So there's a little
bit more work
needed beyond just showing
that there's [INAUDIBLE],,
but identifying this
kind of topology
in the plus and minus conditions
led to the discovery of gluons
in this kind of conditions.
So that was my introduction.
As a next step, I want to
add one more step of, now,
how can we learn about
this kind of structures
before we then dive
into Feinmann diagrams,
or Feinmann calculations,
Feinmann rules for QCD.